Remember your boss in Toy City Part One?
Well they loved your sales report so
much they decided to surprise you
with an extra fun, special request.
Your boss thinks they might
be able to save Toy City
if they can convince investors
to invest in the company.
They've asked you to print
the sales report to a file so
they can easily share
the reports with investors.
Your boss was also wondering if you
could somehow package up the code.
So they can re-use pieces of
it in future sales reports.
In this lesson, you're going to
use the new skills you've learned
to re-factor your code
from Toy City Part One.
You'll then restructure your
code using methods, and
output your reports to a file,
instead of just the command line.
You'll also start using Get to
track your changes that you make to
the project files.
All right, let's get started.